when you put a baby and discussion of
politics together
you're just guaranteed to not have sleep
[Music]
so today I'm gonna be partnered with
someone who identifies as conservative
she happens to be a liberal and so we're
gonna both jointly take care of a robot
baby together I've never held a baby
before I'm a held at one time maybe an
actual baby toddler yes
but baby no I do also know that no oh no
Chuy
yeah okay yeah I could either do the
bouncy are you crying that was oh that's
what I needed that was only like the
biggest restful I was sure will be
receiving a score a percentage score
from one to a hundred
hopefully we do well know people gonna
think that we're crazy for carrying this
thing around
yes let's embrace it this is the car
seat of the future guys it's not please
don't never do this at home I'm gonna
see you hear it tonight so yeah we will
reconnect then uh see you tonight
see Michael so I'm gonna have to go into
the grocery store with this one here and
I'm kind of concerned when we were
together it was much more fun to see
everyone else's reactions but then I
feel like when I went out alone it's
like you just want to be like just
disregard this lump that's under my
shirt
okay at least it's happening now or not
in the grocery store why does it [ __ ] so
much fog of the year oh yeah what up
talk about Trump and I didn't actually
vote for Trump we're about to go on
YouTube and look at some stuff that he
said makes you tick or what makes you
yell even what you believe we kind of
came around to issues like I I'm trying
to say something but I don't know quite
how to say it yet and then we kept
talking like okay now I kind of know
like once it kind of like felt like
everything filled in I started to talk
about um Gavin McGinnis do you agree
like with some of the position positions
he takes but he's going about it like a
dick he thinks it's funny though I mean
I just yeah I don't choose the things I
can take the perspective of someone that
believes otherwise and it's like why
would I why would I want to I were if I
were know it in every minute we realized
that afterwards we've been talking for
just someone from twelve one to five
straight hours I'm alive she's alive if
he wasn't keeping us up we were keeping
each other yeah so it was gonna happen
anyways every time I've had a
conversation with someone who doesn't
have similar beliefs things get really
heavy but I actually left this
conversation pretty darn happy it's 4:30
a.m. why is my baby still eating yeah oh
look at that
look at you yeah this kid is getting
gonna go up this entire Hill and he's
been so good yeah he's gonna carry him
up so I talked to Kevin my water bottle
in this situation we found out yes we
are striving towards the same things we
go things about it in a different way
and I think when we talked about it in
the context of Michael like oh if our
child ended up growing up you know as
gay so would it make any difference to
you if our baby he grew up and he came
out as gay with that impact you
personally
some people are [ __ ] they're gonna
do things based on what they know you
can take it personally or you can just
move on he never used his tone of voice
in a way that was discriminative or put
me down and I've been in that situation
many times before so if that didn't
occur I don't I don't think I would have
listened I don't think I would have
cared if he decided that
she wanted to go and advocate something
that wasn't like you know what you
believed in
would you be like do what you want to do
I'm up I'm not gonna support you a lot
of people do jump to the conclusion or
to certain assumptions without enough
data and I think that's important for
you to make your own decisions to speak
on the black lives matter think there
are issues that are still needing to be
addressed like those are real and so if
my son feels and really takes those on
as his own I'm for that at least he's
doing something that you literally look
like you're working out with Michael
Debbie I was mid shower and maybe my god
started a diet crying so I guess I'm not
going to just know anymore
baby is not perfect in like straight-up
20 minutes he's so much more of a mom
than I am I just thought about single
motherhood a lot whenever he was gone
and I was like you know if I don't get
married I'll just adopt a kid I'll be
fun can you give me the bottle again
yeah I [ __ ] hate this baby my beliefs
I'm sticking to my guns in terms of like
my conservative views and Natalie's
sticking to her guns through all of that
one we were so respectful to each other
and I was able to kind of get where she
was coming from as I do think that she
really did get where I was coming from
kind of amazing like having a one-on-one
time with somebody who is willing to
listen and willing to evaluate your
values and beliefs in a non-critical
kind of a way as I genuinely believe
that politics make up who you are
talking to her at length really made me
understand the other side a lot more
having something like this medium like a
baby to care for put stuff in
perspective like you know there's policy
and there's all these different kinds of
things but like when we have something
that's like right here
we have to take care of together those
things end up being kind of meaningless
in a way okay so we're here at the end
it's 10 p.m. which means baby is off
which means I can no service looks up no
92% oh we got nay - is any - there's a
that's on the birds baby we had so many
discussions where our desire was really
to find a solution rather than tickin
tenuously butt heads over a subject that
we don't agree with whether I may not
believe with agree with it right now
through more conversation you never know
like you you have to be at least open
and not close-minded to like accept some
other way to do it it is all about
common understanding and empathy and
your being able to kind of see it from
the other side's perspective I do think
if that stuff is in place it does
actually work out it's kind of nice to
be able to prove that until I tell
people that what the media says about
the two different groups or whatever
sides that there are like it may not
necessarily be true so that's what I
felt like this project did for me or for
us can I do it yeah yeah
[Laughter]
he says that